محطة الفضاء الدولية هذه
بيكي أندرسون في الإمام كان
مركز الرشيد للفضاء في دبي كيف
تقرأ
والعودة هنا هذا أه سلطان العضدي
من محطة الفضاء الدولية في
ردهة هوبي واضح
رائع إنه لأمر رائع أن أتحدث
إليكم اليوم كيف حالكم  أنت
أقوم بعمل رائع بيكي إنه أه أه
الحلم أصبح حقيقة العيش على متن
محطة الفضاء الدولية لا يمكن أن
يكون أفضل
هذه مقابلة خارج العالم
الفضاء هو أول عربي يتم
نشره على المدى الطويل  مهمة في الكون
عميلان بكامل طاقتهما
وانطلق إلى محطة الفضاء الدولية في مهمة مدتها ستة أشهر
بالشراكة مع وكالة ناسا
وشركة الاستكشاف SpaceX.
عندما رأيت الأرض لأول مرة، كانت
لحظة عميقة حيث كنا نطير على ارتفاع 400
كيلومتر تقريبًا فوق سطح الأرض.  هذا الكوكب
وترى كل ما تراه الجبال
والغابات والصحاري وكل ما
تعرفه ومن
الرائع حقًا أن ترى هذا الكوكب الرائع
لا يزال يحاول أن يريني ما حوله والذي
يبدو وكأنه بيئة مزدحمة حقًا
أنت فيها  فقط اشرح مكانك وما
يعنيه كل هذا وأنت تطفو رأسًا على
عقب،
لذلك في الشهر الأول هنا بيكي كان لدينا
مهمة شحن كانت مليئة بالعلم
لذلك كان لدينا الكثير من
التجارب العلمية واختبرنا الأدوية
واختبرنا التقنيات التي اختبرناها  الكثير
من الأشياء التي ربما نختبرها لأول
مرة وهي
تقنية متطورة لذلك كنت أقوم بتسلسل الحمض النووي وكنت
أضع بعض الأدوية على
أنسجة القلب وفوق كل ذلك نحن
نخضع أنفسنا لذلك، لدينا تجارب
وأجهزة استشعار تعمل فقط على أنسجة القلب لدينا  الأجسام
طوال المهمة لنكون قادرين على
فهم كيفية تأثير الجاذبية الصغرى على
جسم الإنسان عندما نفكر في
العودة إلى القمر أو الذهاب
إلى الفضاء إلى المريخ وما إلى ذلك بصرف النظر
عن
التجارب العلمية، يقضي النياري أيامه في
إجراء الإصلاحات على حد سواء  داخل وخارج
المحطة الفضائية
[موسيقى]
دخل رائد الفضاء الإماراتي سلطان أوناتي إلى جزء قفل الطاقم من
غرفة معادلة الضغط الخاصة بالمهمة
أخبرني عن The Space Walk Sultan
مذهلة أو مرعبة كتجربة
على حد سواء وفي الواقع الاسم هو السير في الفضاء
لكننا لا نسير  نحن نستخدم أيدينا لذا
نحتاج إلى سواعد قوية جدًا حتى
نتمكن من الانتقال من مكان إلى
آخر، لذلك كان الأمر رائعًا، لقد كانت سبع
ساعات متواصلة ولم أشعر بذلك
لأنني كنت أركز حقًا في
المهمة وقد كانت كذلك  لقد كان
شعورًا رائعًا حقًا أن ترى أنك
تطفو في بدلة فضائية، فهي تشبه تمامًا
مركبة فضائية صغيرة، فهي توفر الأوكسجين
وثاني أكسيد الكربون للتنظيف والتبريد، وما
يمنعك من الموت هو تمامًا
مثل طبقة صغيرة من محطة زجاجية، هذه
هي هيوستن ACR  وهذا يختتم الحدث